i mean i had
i had something i [ __ ] zac efron oh
yeah
what's up with zac efron
we're all dying to know dude we all
gotta
[Music]
yeah he's like well it's weird because
he's like a
a pretty i mean he's a really nice dude
great guy but like he yes he is like a
super hot
super hot dude i fee for whatever reason
that i keep getting cast
like opposite like honky dudes like
honky dudes and then i'm like the
regular guy schlub that i think
america can relate to and they're like
yeah i'm kind of like him and then
there's always that
[ __ ] hunk over there and um
and i because i worked with liam
hemsworth in a movie
isn't it romantic and also he's the same
thing where it's just like you're just
like jesus christ like
you won't you like you won't see him for
a while and then you'll he'll be like
you're at craft services or whatever and
then all of a sudden zach or liam is
like right next to you and you're like
jesus
god damn you're sexy you know yeah
hotter off camera than they are on
camera
but specifically yeah the camera can't
capture all that beauty but uh
specifically i saw like grown women
like 50 year old women like melt in
front of him
like act like little girls like oh and
like
objectify him in a way that i've never
seen a man
objectify well i take that back good
because
i've been to straight clubs but um but
uh
no like just like truly just like melt
in front of him i'm like oh this is
weird dude and he's like yeah it's so
weird like he's like
i don't even like to if i see like a
pack of like 50 year old women i try to
steer clear because they
they will just lose their minds and i'm
like yeah that's that is a weird
i don't have that problem at all
poor guy me it's like 20 30 years old
dudes i'm like [ __ ] i gotta
yeah some kids with a skateboard you're
like let's let's get out of here
it's like like denny's at like two in
the morning it's like [ __ ] dude okay
going that way and you know
zac efron's like dude there's like hot
milk sort of trying to [ __ ]
way too much [ __ ] over there
yeah he's like oh god i can't even walk
past that
jesus christ were you uh
in hawaii with zach when he [ __ ] rode
the tiger shark
yeah dude we were together uh ocean
ramsay ocean ramsay that's right he goes
you know it's early on in shooting the
movie and zach is like
yo dude uh tomorrow i gotta set up you
wanna go uh shark diving
and i'm like no but i'm trying to be
i'm not i'm trying to like fit in you
know it's like my first
star role in the movie so i'm like well
if he's doing it i guess i should do it
and i went and dude that was like the
[ __ ] scariest thing
first of all didn't know i got seasick
wildly seasick
and so we get out there and she's like
it'll actually be better once you're in
the water
and uh and i go oh okay and i get in the
water
and they she's like if any of the sharks
are being aggressive i'll i'll like
tell you this shark and and she's like
if they pop their gills out and if they
come up next to you and hip check you
that's they're like sizing you up and
i'm like oh
okay sure enough there's like 17
sharks in the water they're they're
[ __ ] everywhere your head's on a
swivel
and this shark comes right up next to me
it's like popping its gills
and just like it comes out of nowhere
from the deep blue
and just hip checks my ass by a [ __ ]
shark
and i'm like oh what the [ __ ] and then
she's like come on come up when i i go
up
and she's like that shark is being
weirdly very aggressive to you i'd
recommend
uh getting back on the boat for a while
and just kind of letting letting him
chill out i'm like
good call and i get on the the boat
puking
zach's zach's in the water he's having a
great time
they're all female sharks like they're
all girls
ovulating and uh
i i get back on the boat now i'm seasick
i'm puking
i'm puking off the i'm chumming the
water with my own vomit
and then she's like what are you doing
you're chumming the water and i'm like
i'm seasick and she goes i'm gonna need
to get back in the water i'm like
with that mean shark she's like just
it'll be fine and we get in
and all this i'm back in the water the
shark is kind of leaving me alone
i'm like oh what the [ __ ] and uh all of
a sudden
the sharks disappear behind me disappear
in front of me
i see them all just like swim off into
the darkness and i'm like
well that's a weird sign and she's like
come up
we we come up ocean ramsay meezak ocean
uh when we we go up and and she's like
hey there must be an apex predator in
the water they're like
more than the sharks and they're like
yeah it's uh either a great white which
i doubt
i think it's probably a tiger shark sure
enough this huge
the thing was like 13 feet long it was
[ __ ]
massive tiger shark and they're like
let's she goes
just it's more interested in the boat
than us
it's it's it's been circling us for a
while uh
let's just stay close to the boat and uh
you know and
let it chill and i'm like i'm gonna stay
on the ladder that's where i'm staying
and uh and the shark is swimming around
zach swims over to it grabs it by its
fin and
rides it as if it's a [ __ ] uh
little little kid ride that you put a
quarter in at like outside of a kmart or
some [ __ ]
and he rides it the shark does nothing
he comes up and we're all like holy [ __ ]
that's insane oh my god and she's like
yeah
definitely don't do that again that is
insane and
we go back down he rides it again this
time the shark like gives him like a
little
like shoulder shimmy uh and just like
sort of wiggled him off
we come back up and we're like oh my god
ocean's like that's crazy definitely
don't do that again
oh holy [ __ ] that's wild
zach does it a third time a third time
grabs it now the shark's just like get
the [ __ ] off me dude like why don't you
keep touching me
and the shark like through like bunk and
bronco style
threw him off and zach like goes flying
in the water
and then comes up and ocean's like
that's great everybody on the boat right
now
that's insane we're done and yeah but
then
you know but in hindsight zach didn't
get bit
nothing bad happened he looks cool as
[ __ ] in the story
uh he got to go on all the talk shows we
he
has a video so we have all this really
cool footage of him like swimming up to
the shark grabbing it by its fin looking
all cool
meanwhile i'm like in the background
like
yeah just puking on myself underwater
swimming swimming backwards like i look
like
such a [ __ ] meanwhile zack's like
looking all cool swimming towards it and
i'm like
aggressively doggy paddling away
yeah dude